there's been a long-running debate as
we've been saying about which emissions
are most damaging petrol or diesel
now while petrol cars have more come
emit more carbon dioxide and hydrocarbon
and are more fuel-efficient on the other
hand diesel engines admit more nitrogen
oxide and dangerous airborne particles
so essentially carbon emissions from
petrol or worse for climate change and
global warming while nitrogen oxides
from diesel are worse for the health of
individuals and can be linked to us for
respiratory problems and heart disease I
mean the interesting thing professor is
that people always used to say well
petrels bad and that diesel was better
but as far as the general environment is
concerned that's not the case well I
think your illustrations how about right
is that the argument in favor of diesels
because of the fuel efficiency the
perception that they can have a more
efficient more miles per gallons that
were but the emissions for my health
perspective are more harmful from diesel
to so when we're talking about petrol in
the end what we're doing is talking
about global warming would that be right
well both both forms of vehicle
transport contributor global warming and
they're not so far different from it but
there is a marginal benefit from diesel
technology for that assuming the
efficiency figures are as as published
well let's look now about diesel this is
this whole question of nitrogen oxides
500,000 premature deaths in Europe and
even suggested that 300 3,500 alone in
London so so so what are these things in
diesel and what do they do well the
evidence about the health effects from
air pollution and karmush in particular
is mainly effects on the particle
component and Diesel's produce diesel
particles which are known to be harmful
to health as indeed are particles from
other sources too interestingly both are
both diesel specifically and air
pollution general has also been
classified as a car
so we know the health effects they
affect them the instance of here cancers
but also in general effect and this
particular nitrogen oxide people are
concerned about I mean as nearly 6000
premature deaths in London this is I
should say this is to 2010 and also an
increase in heart disease
yes well the the debate about nitrous
oxide is is somewhat complicated because
as I indicated the evidence is really
strong for particles and it's less clear
where the nitrogen oxides have an
independent and an additional effect on
health but there is some evidence for
that which I think will only become
clarified over the next few years at the
moment it's impossible to say
confidently whether nitrogen oxides
contribute to the health risks beyond
that that's due to particles but there
are suspicions and I suppose that means
that conceivably this is what we're
talking about the only cause of these of
pollutants they're also in the
atmosphere as well it's probably
unlikely tobacco industry almost
couldn't have put the focus on the
danger of her well I mean it it's
unquestionably
pollution general is I'm questioning one
of the leading environmental health
problems today it accounts for three
half million deaths worldwide premature
deaths worldwide 400,000 in Europe as
you've indicated probably nearly 30
thousand 29 50,000 the UK it's something
which we need to take action on and that
can only be achieved by a variety of
technological changes and some behavior
contributions to and this is a prime
case I mean the point is what's going on
because these VW cars under scrutiny
this week thought to be admitting
anything up to 40 times the pollution
standard set by the EPA and although
other brands have been implicated
directly a recent report found that 9
out of 10 are breaking now this is the
use is all America a new pollution
limits yes I mean that's gonna certain
there's that testing and test conditions
is not the way the engine may not
necessarily behave in real world driving
and if the emissions are substantially
higher it means we aren't very clear
therefore exactly how we're trying to
achieve the targets of reducing
pollutants both particles and nitrogen
oxides what do you think finally the
lesson of all the
should be well I think it's a less of
hard lesson for Volkswagen that they
they need to not try to circumvent the
test procedures because they've been
found out apparently in the end but
there is a general lesson for all of us
is that we need to have relentless
attention to try and reduce emissions in
general from all cars not just these
press workers and thank you